I think I know why you're happy I know
why you're happy I know I said I know
could you guess why today because today
Mitt Romney formally announced he's
running for the Senate in Utah ladies
and gentlemen Mitt Romney remember when
every liberal in the world hated Mitt
Romney and thought he was the worst
person in the world now every time I see
him I'm like who knew we had a decent
same Mormon who believed in the planet
Kolob who could run the country well the
other good news Bob Muller indicted this
is big I know I know this is a slow
moving story the indictments and it's
like a eyes glaze this was big today he
indicted 13 Russian nationals three
Russian companies for their plot
[Music]
for their plot to use social media to
rat-fuck our 2016 elections you know how
Trump boys has no collusion it's getting
close the indictment the indictment says
the Russians were in communication with
unwitting individuals associated with
the Trump administration yeah that's the
problem unwitting it could have been
anybody you know it but it goes into
this indictment goes into great detail
about how when these Russians posed as
Americans to sow discord among us they
went to great lengths to appear like
there were regular real Americans they
bought space on American web service
they used American slang they gained 50
pounds and you know I just want to ask
the Trump voters I know you're out there
does that be you Audrey what is left for
you
he's plainly a traitor who doesn't
defend his own country
and released his budget this week
remember during the campaign he said I
would never cut Medicare like the other
I would never cut the budget cuts
hundreds of billions of dollars these
Trump supporters they're not
conservatives they're drew Barrymore in
50 first dates if you lose your memory
every night it all starts to make sense
and then Trump's EPA chief you know this
guy Scott Pruett um the things climate
change is a hoax he's under fire because
he's been flying first-class and the
reason he says he has to is cuz people
in coach yell at him he says it's a very
toxic environment politically you know
what else is a very toxic environment
the environment that's the EPA job yeah
crazy and they get away with all these
serious crimes because they distract us
with their silly sex scandals you know
now on top of stormy Daniels well I mean
funny even what L mean to be
on top of this door me Daniel scandal
The New Yorker is running an article now
that says he had an affair Trump hadn't
if I run the same time with the Playboy
Playmate named Karen McDougal
it was the same year as the stormy
Daniels thing Melania was just right
ever having a baby and so he was he was
cheating on his newlywed wife and his
newborn baby with a porn star and a
playmate Mike Pence your thoughts Karen
McDougal I guess it was destined that
you would wind up with Trump I checked
her a playmate datasheet today I have
all the back issues and it said her
turtles were fat liars who smell like
KFC so it was in the stars now and she
says after the first time they had sex
he offered her money and every time
after that he just said Mexico's gonna
pay for
but you know you know how they paid her
off
Trump's buddies at the National Enquirer
give her 150 thousand dollars for the
rights to her story and then didn't run
it see inquire yeah their readers are
the same demographic as the Trump voter
old white angry and challenged by the
world's easiest crossword puzzle
now stormy Daniels got paid off we found
this week by well this is what he says
Michael Cohen Trump's mall lawyer who
says he paid stormy out of his own
pocket 130,000 dollars even stormy said
that's hard to swallow and I'm a porn
star anyway thank you Republican for
once again restoring honor and dignity
to the Oval Office and just in time for
President's Day is Monday president
thanks yes it's nice that we still live
in a country where any child can grow up
to be the next Lincoln and by that I
mean get killed with a gun
I know but we have to hear it I mean
after that horrible shooting in Florida
Trump never mentioned guns pivoted right
to the NRA talking points he said so
many signs at the Florida shooter was
mentally disturbed yes we saw he was
wearing a make America great again hack
and then yesterday Trump finally spoke
he said we must work together to create
a culture in this country that creates
deep and meaningful human connections
like I have with my kids Ivanka Don jr.
what's-her-face and the other one